one other Trump interview I want to look
at before we move on from yesterday and
this is really interesting Trump was
interviewed by Rob Schmidt on Newsmax
Rob Schmidt is one of the people that
went after me about a month and a half
ago
uh when I pointed out prayer doesn't
prevent mass shootings Rob Schmidt
jumped on the uh the bandwagon this is
just fascinating Trump
claims during this interview that he got
rid of Roe v Wade this this is very
interesting and consequential listen to
this your response to his allegation on
this and I want to ask also do you think
that six weeks is is going too far is
that going to Doom Republicans with the
moderates in this country when it comes
to 2024.
Rob first of all I'm the one that got
rid of Roe v Wade and everybody said
that was an impossible thing to do I put
on three Supreme Court Justices very few
people have had that privilege or honor
and uh they are terrific people and they
happen to believe uh that Roe v Wade
should not be there it's been now
brought back to the States and what I've
done is I've given the pro-life people
who are wonderful people and loving
people I've given them the power of
negotiation because now they're able to
negotiate something that's going to be
very important
so Trump saying he really got rid of Roe
v Wade by virtue of having appointed the
Supreme Court Justices he appointed I
would agree I actually Trump shockingly
not lying at least metaphorically about
that the midterm voters noticed and they
voted the way they did in part because
of that this should be a democratic
campaign ad paid for by Joe Biden right
I'm Joe Biden and I approve this message
Trump saying I'm the one that got rid of
Roe v Wade if indeed Trump is the
Republican nominee then Trump went back
to the lies including laughably claiming
that the Durham report is the biggest
story in the history of the United
States
this is the biggest story of
maybe in the history of our country at
the time of the century uh look at what
they report on on other people I won't
mention names other people where they're
they're caught cold they're criminals
and they don't even report they refuse
to you know you can't have a scandal if
you don't have publicity to be honest
you cannot have a scandal now of course
I already told you about the truth of
the Durham report it is not exposing the
crime of the century in fact the report
even says we're not aware of any crimes
at all committed by anyone in the
investigation of Donald Trump through
the Mueller investigation that's in the
Mueller report that's in the Durham
report rather and Trump continues to lie
and lie and lie and by the way we still
haven't figured out what Obama gate is
Trump told us obamigate biggest
political crime of the century I don't
know which century
um and we still don't even know what
Obama gate is and then lastly Trump
Lament hunting that they want to fire
the head of CNN after that big beautiful
Town Hall that Trump did we're doing
before what they do seven eight nine
months
into a birth or a child the life of a
child those are the radical people not
the pro-life people those are the
radical people and I think I explained
it very well the other night on uh on
CNN you know so well that they want to
fire the head of CNN they want to fire
elect he got they had the highest
ratings that they had in many years and
they want to go out and they want to
fire licks so you know you explained
that one the whole world is topsy-turvy
and what I say yeah it's a topsy-turvy
world out there now the truth is
CNN's ratings for the Trump Town Hall
weren't actually that great it was about
3 million which actually is quite good
for CNN in the sense that CNN ratings
are in the toilet and actually this is
insane but Newsmax had higher viewership
than CNN during some prime time hour
late last week or earlier this week
which which is genuinely stunning stuff
I mean it shows you the the lack of
interest in what CNN is offering it's
not really true though that the the CNN
Town Hall ratings were that great what
happened was Trump's behavior on the
town hall was so outrageous
that after the fact
the reality of CNN doing the town hall
is what made news and the disaster of
Caitlin Collins's attempts to kind of
hold Trump accountable and the lie a
second that Trump told that's what got
attention Trump likes to think oh CNN
Live got a huge ratings boost because of
me the truth is Trump's Behavior was so
deplorable during the town hall that
after the fact anybody who pays
attention to what's going on in the 2024
race certainly commented on it so the
lies just spewing out of Trump's mouth
but he's clearly doing something that's
impressing the Republican primary voters
because he keeps building his lead over
to santis in the primary polls as we
talked about at the top of the show
let's take a quick break all of these
clips I played are going to be on our
Instagram on our YouTube channel on our
Tick Tock check them out there and we'll
be right back
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpicks.com today save 10 with
the code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below